so I'm going to write out a number then
we're going to think about how we could
say or actually write that number so I'm
just going to write it out I'm going to
have to resist the temptation to
actually speak it out because that's
normally how I operate but I'm not going
to do that right now I'm not going to do
that right now so there's several ways
that we can pronounce it encourage you
to pause it and try to pronounce it
yourself you might not even need to
pause it well the first thing that jumps
out well we've got 20,000 and then some
so maybe we should write it that way so
we've got we've got 20,000 20 actually
let me write it out as numbers first to
really decompose it so we have 20,000
and then what do we have on top of that
well we have 5/10 this is the tenths
place so we could literally write that
as 5/10 5/10 then we have 0 0 hundredths
I'll write that as a hundredths place
just so that we can keep track of it and
then finally we have 7 thousandths
that's the thousandths place so we could
write that plus 7 thousandths so if we
were to write down everything I just did
I just spoke out loud we would say that
this is 20 let me write that a little
bit neater
this is 20,000 20,000 and 5 tenths and 5
write out the word and 5 tenths and 7
thousandths and 7 thousandths now this
isn't the only way to say this another
way of thinking about it is to try to
merge the five tenths and the 7
thousands in terms of thousands so let's
think about this so we could write this
as so once again we would have our
20,000 20,000 instead of five tenths and
seven thousand so let's write our five
tenths in terms of thousands and the
easiest way to do it is to multiply the
numerator in the denominator
both here by a hundred so then we will
have so this five tenths is the same
thing as five hundred over a thousand
and the seven tenths is or the seven
thousand two still seven thousands and
these two combined are five hundred and
seven over a thousand five hundred seven
over a thousand so we could just call
this twenty thousand and five hundred
and seven thousand so let's write that
down so we could just say this is 20,000
20,000 and and five hundred and seven
five hundred and seven thousands
thousands thousands thousands this is
one over a thousand while this right
over here thousand of course actually
represents one thousand so we got 20
thousands that's that right over there
and five hundred seven thousandths